Governor Newsom there unveiling a plan
to build 1200 tiny houses to help
address the state's homeless crisis each
one measures about 10 square meters and
takes about 90 minutes to build here's
Governor Newsom
we set aside 750 million dollars to do
this
encampments
their encampment resolution grants so we
can address what's happening on the
streets when that individual is ready
that we have a place to go or at least
another option in terms of the
alternatives to living out in the
streets and sidewalks join me now is the
host of the Reuben report Dave Rubin he
used to live in California so we're
going to tap into his expertise want to
show you something you probably already
know this is California's homeless
population it is distressing they have
there's a lot of them there and then if
you look at the so now in 2022 171
000 are homeless that's the numbers that
they have and as a percentage of the U.S
homeless population that's 30 percent
so California does have a huge problem
does this idea with tiny houses
get to a solution that everybody can
live with
well I'd actually like to give Gavin
Newsom credit Believe It or Not Dana
because nobody on Earth in the history
of the world is better at creating
homeless people than Gavin Newsom and he
deserves credit for that you know when
he was San Francisco mayor back in 2008
he had like a 10-year plan to eliminate
homelessness there's a video that's
going viral uh that explains that people
can check it out my Twitter's at Reuben
report if you want to see that he has
ruined San Francisco as mayor he has
ruined California as governor and if you
think that 1200 homes are going to do
anything about the homeless problem
which has far more to do with fentanyl
and meth and the General State of
lawlessness that the progressives and
the Democrats and the one-party state
that is California have caused I mean
it's not going to stop anything you know
these people have serious drug problems
they have serious psychological problems
on top of the economic conditions as I
said that that the Democrats have
created so there's a hundred other
issues that should be dealt with to help
these people if you believe the state
has that role and then we can talk about
housing but relative to housing
California also has some of the highest
taxes in the nation some of the craziest
regulation related to buildings so
Builders don't want to even build their
end uh you know all of the high income
earners are fleeing the state so you're
getting less tax revenue for these crazy
Adventures that Gavin wants to go on he
also announced some additional monies
that will be going to some cities as
they try to tackle this as well and like
a billion dollars here a billion dollars
there and there's a state leader of the
California state senate his name is
Brian Jones and this is what he said
this is just another Band-Aid on a
crisis that is out of control in
California we know that throwing money
at this problem doesn't work David now
that you've had some distance from
California and you've seen in Florida
how the system works a lot differently
is there anything you think that Gavin
Newsom could actually do to try to get
people to stop coming to their state
because what you're pointing out is that
a lot a lot of these people who are
homeless they want to be there they have
the conditions maybe they don't want to
be homeless but they want to be left
alone but this tiny house idea it might
look good on paper but how long do you
think that that lasts
well of course there's something Gavin
Newsom could do he could resign that
would be the honorable thing to do
everything he touches he destroys at
least in the public domain now on the
private side his wineries as you
probably heard uh just got bailed out
because they had all their money in svb
bank which he then lobbied Joe Biden to
bail out which they did and it turns out
that apparently Gavin also had his
private money there so he's good with
his private stuff and helping his own
wineries but everything else he touches
is garbage I can tell you having moved
to Florida for the last 15 months will I
live in Miami right now we have under a
thousand homeless people here we have
all-time low unemployment they are
building like crazy because DeSantis is
is escalating projects because we have
1200 people moving here every day uh and
if Gavin Newsom you know if he's
thinking about running for uh president
which it seems like it's all heading in
that direction I mean the proof is in
the pudding about a million people have
fleed California since covid began and
Florida's picked up about a million
Tennessee Tech Texas all of these red
states are picking up people and and the
question of course always remains will
these people vote the right way I'm
happy to say that everyone that I meet
here seems like they know what they fled
uh but there's nothing else Gavin Newsom
can do I guarantee you this project will
do nothing but suck off more money and
it will create no less homelessness and
it will just checking on boondoggle
which is exactly what the Democrats love
yeah we'll check out I mean we everybody
would like a solution so if we hit upon
one great but this one might not be it
Dave thanks good to see you have a great
weekend
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell